hey Hoss go bro success haha Oh Edgar
farted welcome to my game PewDiePie
legend of the brofist there's tickets
maybe eight to nine months outer - the
developers did such a great job this has
been a best-seller on iOS Android and
you bro us up you're just loving it I've
been loving how much you're loving it
but the time has finally come for me to
play it for you Bruce I'm also gonna do
a challenge so if you can beat my high
score
I will pick three winners every day how
you make bread using your butt cheeks if
you tweet at me with a hashtag beat the
pro and you beat if you beat the game on
the hardest difficulty pug mode send it
to me
thanks for watching and you might win
something always stay awesome this is al
are they recreated my room like I live
in the Thai I'm recording the tiniest
space ever it gets so [ __ ] hot I have
no ventilations I love that painting I
miss it but here we go this is my setup
[Music]
so weird love this music yes I'm done I
wonder how many views my last video guy
well you gotta check the views that's
just how it is
how to make bread using a butt cheek
that should get a lot of use what what
what 0-0 that's weird
[Music]
still got it
oh [ __ ] ah those damn those damn barrels
and now it's your turn to be contained
you damn barrels yeah damn barrels
if you don't hate barrels like if you
didn't hate barrels before you sure as
hell will hate Paris
never capture me contain contain contain
what the hell is going on what the hell
is going on might see in seep she's safe
I would not do that I would just I would
just keep making videos thank you very
much
there we go this is the game how to play
no thank you I know how to play this
game I'm actually playing a PC version
of the game so it's a little cheating of
me but actually the game runs
surprisingly well as as applied for
Merona tablet or iOS devices so here we
are this is actually much this room in
Italy it looks really like I love they
recreated what can be underneath all
these clothes Marcia Marcia what were
you doing there Oh God the pedals keep
coming
I gotta collect all the Brooklands but I
forgot early fed your painting
Edgar joins a party oh god sanic barrels
kill them no whatever might why did they
keep breaking my house this couch
actually we don't have anymore because
Edgar kept peeing in it
so thanks Edgar so basically you collect
the broke oins
and you use them to unlock abilities
later in the game unlock characters
you'll be able to unlock Marzia and a
bunch of other youtuber friends how you
should I'm sure you know this already I
just have to say it I just to make sure
that you know it here we go dig up some
more [ __ ] god dammit that desk gotta
have my headphones 100% [ __ ] that sanic
barrel okay this thing takes screenshots
this is really hard to commentate over
because so much [ __ ] [ __ ] is going on
got an stefano yarn supporting there
wouldn't be a party put it by party with
that stefano would it oh god alright
by the way my house is not this big I do
not live in a [ __ ] mansion
I love the pixel art though it's so
beautiful [ __ ] you sanic barrel in the
leaves you can find secret patches maybe
extra life this one is a static barrel
patch
then non-copyright version oh god can we
make it in time can't we make it in time
yes dr. crab he's very useful in this
game cuz he has a doctorate if you get
hearts when you have full heart you get
a lot of broke wins it's very important
to collect bro corn Royales this game is
gonna be very hard this game is
extremely hard I've got a killed mama
barrel mama barrel has the little babies
in her side her it's really dark and
horrible to get up here you have to jump
ah God I didn't time it right I'm sorry
baby barrels there Cho cute there we go
ah [ __ ] I didn't time it right yes okay
that's a dude you're gonna hold down
there the jump button had a lot of
pretty a lot of your breasts are asking
about it there's a lot of secrets to
this game we I honestly didn't think
some of your brothers would never find
them but it's really funny to see you
tweet me when you find like a little
easter egg or some [ __ ] like that
oh god mama barrel here we go we only
have one pug left Maya yay the whole
party's here what else could be past oh
my god I can't kill the baby barrels I'm
sorry my heart can't go on Oh guys sanic
well here we go last item what could it
be
car case ok time to leave can't stay in
this house but first the bro codes there
we go
oh the Burger King let's see if you bros
can recognize who the barrel king is
all your pants I really did this we did
this when I recorded the lines I'm like
I captured all your fast I don't know
it's really hard to do your own voice in
like a regular way especially when other
people are in the studio looking at you
I'm like legendary bro fit you'll see
later they come out kind of awkwardly
but I think it's kind of funny I can do
voices like barrel King cos I'm doing a
boys if I do my so the story so far that
barrel King has captured all my fans and
there's no point of running
oh thanks my dad might say was gay boys
actor actress
yes of course we surf the car what
she wasn't supposed to say that
yeah we beat Beauty times oh yes we got
a snappy photo where we can share that
we beat the game and easy that's not
that impressive we'll share if we Peter
Lonard
they asked me which dancing animation I
want and I'm like twerking no question
about it
as you can see we get bonus broke lines
we get a performance bonus I think
that's based on time and then we get an
extra perk or bonus for how many pugs
survived and a difficulty multiplier so
it pays off to play on the harder
difficulties if you're going to unlock
stuff so here we have the Pens menu this
is all the level menu we can now well
look Marzia this is are all the levels
there's no I think there's 19 levels in
the game it's [ __ ] awesome and
they're all have great variation as well
we can now get dr. crab who we should
probably unlock dr. crab actually how
much is he
hell yeah he's [ __ ] awesome dr. crab
chose to his medicine skills and heals
three hearts hey don't laugh he's a real
doctor
duck mode but she only paid if I can
unlock I think it's my favorite bility
let's unlock Marzia she's a great
character the most fabulous beauty and
makeup oriented videos out there her
sense of style is off the hook who are
all these characters I don't know whoa
that looks like a duck the duck is my
favorite character in the whole game
seriously patches you can unlock all of
them I could cheat and actually unlock
everything because I have the cheap
version of the game it looks beautiful
if you collected all of them let me just
say that okay should be unlock I think
we can get Edgar fart ah we need five
more brook lines and your sports are
very deadly let me tell you they're a
very tactical advantage there we go next
level will be highway frenzy well play a
smart C on this one we have our powerup
but we're gonna play it on hard from now
on here we go
Bart might return how the [ __ ] did he
get attack
oh [ __ ] I got it save this level you got
to move forward well you'll be blown up
it's really hard but it's a really cool
level and we have the pugs to help us
now
so if you haven't seen it already the
pugs will play a key part in this game
because they if you fail they'll jump in
and save you it's really dark it's funny
how some people have been like oh that's
too much they can't do that it's just
cute they do anything for us to live
they're just good dogs and it's a game
get over yourself
ok what's shopping the gas pearls can we
get in time can we get in time Oh God Oh
God oh [ __ ]
no Vienna yeah goddamn it Maya I'm sorry
don't worry
they're not dead forever I have to get
all the unlockables obviously here's
another one
Oh God we're running out of time we're
running out of time not again not again
that again that again oh it was only
hard come on if I won it hearts No thank
God oh [ __ ] this is going terribly
activate dr. kramm dr. Crabbe give me
your hearts thanks dr. Crabbe this part
is too tricky okay
like even though I finished this game so
many times I still struggle because the
game is just so hard
broke truck yeah fills up all our hearts
gas barrel [ __ ] off take me goddamn
ducks if you didn't hate ducks and
barrels before you play this game you
sure as hell will once you're done with
that duck duck dodge duh duck hold down
jump and you will jump higher can we
find a patch here maybe
no just hearts [ __ ] these eggs
another egg weak like it Crockett that's
English
oh god I hate these metal barrels let's
kill them fast their pain in the ass
yeah go setting barrel you [ __ ] okay
bro we got a lot of Brooklyn so far this
is great boom [ __ ] oh god gasps pearl
come here come here you stupid hoe yeah
I get red barrel [ __ ] out of mine
struck alright we're all of us by the
end this part is super tricky Dutch jump
judge Jim come on yeah yeah get at
nobody run markiplier is calling me mark
is so gonna voice acting it feels more
natural
everyone did an amazing job at the voice
ID I'm so glad everyone helped out it's
lit it's literally just friends helping
me out and I really really appreciate
them doing that
oh that just something I got
triple on baby triple dad man that user
life must be really paying off and we
beat highway frenzy my sis dance yes
she always says like this so now we get
double broke coins because we did it on
hard
we got a snappy we've been in hard I
feel like that's shareable but I'm
playing on not a phone so and we are
luck
that's third level okay I'm gonna end
that episode there this is a great
beginning tweet at me beat the bro if
you got a higher point in bro points
than I did and the highest one will win
a prize so just so glad for all the
amazing support in this game it's been
it's such a big and scary project to do
a game like it could go either way
there's so many factors to it
and I really really appreciate you bros
spending time and playing this and even
spending money on it I know some people
didn't want to spend money on it but it
costs so much to make games it's such a
risky thing to do and the developers
really have earned it as well just thank
you for watching and leaving a like and
I'll see you bros in the next one we'll
continue this journey I'll do a little
more levels in the next one and that's
all for now as always stay awesome bros
you